what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video today I will be
talking about Samwell Tarly as of right
now he still has a very big role to play
in the upcoming war but what will Sam do
afterwards I have noticed a few people
asking me this question so I figured I
would give my opinion on what I think
Sam will do once all of the fighting has
stopped as we all know Samwell Tarly is
a man of the Nights Watch he did swear
an oath to pledge his life and his
honors to the Nights Watch for all
nights to come
but will Sam ever go back personally I
don't think he ever will and by the end
of this video I will tell you why the
last time we saw Sam was in the season 7
finale he had just arrived at Winterfell
after his short stint in Old Town where
he was training to become a new maester
of the Citadel for the Nights Watch
Sam had intended on becoming the new
maester at Castle black after maester
aemon passed away and one of the biggest
motivating factors for Sam to go to old
town was so that he could help John for
when the time came to fight the others
Sam was certain that he could find the
information there that was needed to
defeat them but after he arrived he
quickly realized he wasn't going to be
taken very seriously nor were they going
to give him much help after brain stark
sent out his ravens to warn everyone
about the threat beyond the wall
Sam noticed the maesters were showing
zero urgency about this situation so in
the middle of the night Sam stole any
book or document that he could find that
he thought could help them beat the
night king then he left the Citadel he
knew time was of the essence and because
he knew he no longer wanted to read
about the deeds done by other men
Sam was now a man of action he plans on
doing everything that he can to help
even if that means he has to give up his
lifelong dream of becoming a maester if
Sam survives all of the upcoming battles
I do not believe he will ever go back to
the Citadel what Sam was able to do in
the season 7 finale is a glimpse of what
he will continue to do throughout season
8 Samwell Tarly and bran stark will
continue to work side by side until they
can figure out what they need to do to
stop the others from advancing any
further I don't know how many of you
watched my recent videos about
Bryan Stark but I believe he will go
back in time to see how they were
stopped the first time Sam was able to
take some books from the Citadel and
there must be something very important
inside one of them and when he finds it
he will tell bran exactly where to look
just like he did what Rhaegar and Lyanna
x' wedding once the war is over same
we'll have a few different options when
it comes to what he wants to do for the
rest of his life
some people believe Sam will return to
the wall but I think the Nights Watch
will be abolished after the Great War is
over when all the fighting is done there
will be a dream for spring a new day
will begin and there will be a glimmer
of hope for the future generations of
Westeros all the old laws and all the
old ways will no longer serve their
purpose once the cripples bastards and
broken things take over let's think
about the original purpose of the wall
in the first place the wall was built to
keep the others out but over time the
Nights Watch forgot to stay true they
had forgotten why they were originally
there and their new purpose was to keep
the wildlings out of Westeros
but the Nights Watch wasn't formed for
that purpose as of right now the Nights
Watch no longer needs to worry about
wildlings breaching their wall all of
the wildlings who survived have already
came south mostly when Jon allowed them
to come through the wall but all of the
other wildling tribes were killed and
then turned into whites and now they are
south of the wall - when the knight Cain
crippled the wall at
eastwatch-by-the-sea he brought every
last moving body south with him and as
of right now there is no one north of
the wall the Nights Watch will no longer
have a reason to still be manning the
wall right now and after the war is over
they will have no reason to go back they
have already foreshadowed how the night
king and his army will fall beric
Dondarrion literally pointed this out
when you killed the night king his
entire army will die with him the night
king will be killed for good this time
there will not be another pact or peace
treaty made the will will be broken and
the Nights Watch will no longer have to
worry about protecting the realm from
the others all of the wildlings that
survived the war will be rewarded for
their service they will be given their
own lands to live on and they will no
longer have a wall keeping them out of
the Seven Kingdoms
I believe Jon and whoever his advisers
are in the end will completely change
the face
of westeros forever what the night king
and his army dead and the wildlings
given the same rights as every other
citizen in Westeros the Nights Watch
will no longer be needed any man of the
Nights Watch who survives the war will
be given his freedom back he will no
longer be forced to spend the rest of
his life on the wall anyone that was
there because they were a criminal will
have to be dealt with accordingly but
even they could be granted another
chance if they fought bravely so what
the Nights Watch being abolished where
and what Samwell Tarly go next I think
there are two good options that I could
see Sam choosing to do Sam already
dropped out of the Citadel and if he is
no longer bound to the Nights Watch he
will be free to do anything that he
pleases he would be free to marry have
children and even hold lands and titles
again Sam's family owns a beautiful
castle in Horn Hill and I could not
blame him for wanting to go back there
to start some sort of normal life with
Gilly and baby Sam I don't think Sam
should spend the rest of his life
serving someone else not unless he
actually wanted to do this not only is
Sam highborn but we all know Sam is a
very decent human being he's a very kind
and friendly person who could do a lot
of good for the realm Sam is a very
intelligent man and I think he deserves
to live his own life Sam's mother and
sister should still be alive too and I
believe they would accept Sam as their
Lord of Hornell Sam was already next in
line to inherit the lands but his father
forced him to join the Nights Watch so
that dick on could inherit everything
but both of them are now dead
if the Nights Watch no longer exists Sam
would no longer have to abide by the
rules but we all know Sam never followed
all of the rules anyway Sam could then
raise his family without having to worry
about his father's threats and Sam and
Gilly should move to horn Hill and start
their own family there they could even
have a child together in the future who
knows but there is one other thing Sam
could do if he would still choose to
serve in some capacity Sam could always
stay in Winterfell there is a maester
already there but Sam could take his
place if he still choose to serve we all
know that John and Sam have a very
strong bond and Sam is now creating a
relationship with bran stark and Sam and
brains relationship will blossom next
season Sam may be the only one who can
actually connect with
on some level and I think the Starks
would absolutely accept Sam into their
service if that's what he wanted to do
Sam will most likely stay by brain side
throughout season eight and depending
how things play out he may want to stay
to help bran for the rest of his life
Sam could also help deliver John and
Danny's baby if they do have a baby
together Sam said he was gonna help
deliver gillies baby and John asked him
if he knew how and Sam said he did read
about it so he could put that to use in
the future if Sam doesn't go back to
Castle black and Sam doesn't go home
then I think him staying in Winterfell
would be a safe bet the Starks will grow
to love Sam just like John did so I
don't see that being a problem but if it
were up to me I would send Sam home and
allow him to make a life for himself
let him raise a family the way he would
have liked to have been raised
Sam has already served that he has
risked his life on multiple occasions
and without his help they would have not
made it this far in my opinion Sam has
earned his freedom from a life of
service but what do you all think what
would you like to see next for same wal
Tarly assuming he lives what can you see
him doing next let me know your thoughts
and opinions on all of this before I go
I just want to give a special thanks to
all of you who have recently supported
me on patreon in one of my last videos I
told you all about some of the issues I
was having with YouTube and HBO and I
was pleasantly surprised by how many of
you listened to my concerns all of you
should know that I love making these
videos for you as much as I can but
recently YouTube and HBO is taking a
significant amount of my monetization
away I now have over 40 videos with
copyright claims on them and that's not
counting all my new videos that get D
monetized as soon as I upload them I
really don't know what's going on but it
nearly crippled my channel but ever
since I mentioned that in my last video
I had about a dozen new people sign up
the patreon and I cannot thank you
enough I have to say I felt embarrassed
to even have to mention the issues with
YouTube and HBO right now but your
donations on patreon did give me some
hope that I could still afford to spend
the amount of time that I do to make
videos even if I did lose some revenue
so from the bottom of my heart thank you
very much have a great day everyone I
will see you in the next one
by
[Music]
[Music]